ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che
cos'è sta roba coming attimo che devo
cioè il portale delle ascom ltte a te io
sono famiglie non sono obama è prima in
tre ragazzi siamo sul gioco horror the è
l'unione tra mike artes lander questo lo
slider rose l'under 21 helander me è più
vengono da me li siamo entrati nel nette
ragazzo ok alla madonna che sappia
peggio di in ascensore e sto coso
fantastico si gratta culo perfetto era
ovvio in un momento così non era una
torcia che ami scusate mi sono dato è
stato fuori tanto dal deretano slider
kraft e vabbè vabbè applausi allora è
partiamo perché ancora non sa così poco
sia caso mistake questo non è lettera
perché c'è un creeper va bene non ho
caldo siamo entrati da qua perfetto a
posto spegnere la torcia che figo tanto
non ho mai visto del fuoco così
realistico su minecraft ragazzi c'è una
cosa almeno che non sia una texture pack
ho trovato una pagina pistola in lui mi
ha rubato eh vabbè tanto le pagine
meramente la soft che figo noi come
facevi a saperlo che faceva sapere cosa
ragazzi mi sembra di giocare veramente
us lander come ai vecchi tempi solo che
è un po pixelato eh va beh quello è un
altro discorso cos'è un pezzo un pezzo
di metallo ma lo posso l'ho preso ce lo
slider man dove loro vedi ma poi lo
slang man è un under meno roseline da me
decidetevi porca tua madre ok niente la
risposta è stata chiara è uno slider me
non è un enorme un ragazzo traeva sei
stronzo come tua sorella mi fai uscire
senza tipo no no no dov'è porca la
[ __ ] sempre li ha sempre non si
muove bene raga non posso più correre
esaurito la corsa non si muove e si
muove stavo scherzando devo prendere
alan doss run ho capito ma non mi fai
gray cece clipper non parlano nel mio
mondo però quindi vedi di fare poco il
furbo che ti esplode il figlio nonché
ragazzi ho trovato un pezzo di metallo
che però non ho capito cosa mi dovrebbe
mai servire per ok c'è un'altra pagina
così si sa in festa sono veloce va beh
questo lo avevamo capito no che [ __ ]
ragazzi la casa è fatta benissimo è
fatta come mai il carnaval e geniale
troppo bello sto ancora metallo ma basta
posso usarla i fiori di meta degli one
rev abbiamo capito ma io voglio usare la
kraft in table posto e ad arabba
affanculo minecraft cruz
sì certo dovrei poter usare tipo il
metallo per farmi tipo l'elmo la spada
non lo so però ragazzino mi funziona la
classe in table quindi [ __ ] xvi a
sarebbero i boiler questi mi chiami
sembrava un tipo delle mucche preoccupa
è da sempre dov'è dov'è calmi calmi
giamo c dove c'è una pagina riga ecco
che gambe sexy la gancia il futuro porca
[ __ ] la [ __ ] ok sono arto sono
bravo io a questi giochi me la cavo
egregiamente bene ragazzi è stato bello
e easy go dei cavalli in questo gioco se
più mas kraft food show live devi
craftare per sopravvivere ma cosa cazzo
kraft che non so non posso far niente
puzzo manager l'hai capito ma non mi fa
scegliere una mazza cosa vuoi che faccia
bene andiamo qui mi ricordo bene la
mappa this lander qua dovrebbe esserci
tipo il mega dildo a questa è la labbro
vabbè più più o meno ragazzi dovremmo ai
soci vicini comunque leggermente
ristretta della mappa originale this
land noi queste minuscole fei metallo e
non capirò mai che cazzo mi serve
minecraft rose porca [ __ ]
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] non un certo
progetto sono cagato addosso è una roba
allucinante la prima sono morto qua
quindi [ __ ] al è il metal almeno a
metano non dovremmo essere a metà manca
manca ancora una poi saremo a metà dei
file flint che fa ma com preserre to
kraft ha posto come cazzo chiuso yabba
dabba doo non mi ricordavo facessero
così qui però fatto un accendino ragazzi
senza kraft integrale si può fare anche
senza però ok
spiegatemi come lo uso adesso però cos'è
del vetro ma che cazzo mi serve del
vetro spiegatemelo vabbè lo prendiamo
prince don breaking dawn allora un po
per ora dimmi che cosa serve il mas
kraft ifis live che cazzo da dove è
uscito eh vabbè è il più bello prima
ragazzi ho dimenticato delle pagine di
sicuro ma non posso tornare lì perché mi
stupro la notte dico ci sono andato
prima no no perfetto questa è una zona
completamente no che bello mi mancasse
cose c'è ma io ma se io entro qua non
posso entrare per fa infatti perché non
c'è il tasto di salto come cazzo shield
don't look
va bene se io però mai menounos colore
ok noi un cazzo io preferisco la play
comunque ragazzi sembra più una mod di
minecraft this land memo che sono sono
veloci ha rotto faceva parte della
pagina ne mancano tipo 2 si era rotto le
palle non mi ricordo più
ok prendi loro aiuto che palle che palle
ragazzi siamo arrivati ad un momento in
cui faccio due passi e sento tipo
l'interferenza meraviglioso data non
aveva acceso la torcia perché orca
[ __ ] eva beh è un attimo madonna
ragazzi fatevi trovare una conserva beh
secondarie qua sotto no e allora sei
stronzo un albero
oddio mi sono caricato in mano si potrà
ok ho trovato il tour nella gara
dovrebbe essere dentro la pagina non c'è
dov'è dove dai min chiamate valcuha due
bimbi tornare in mente il tipo i ricordi
quando non trovavo le cose che mi
incazzavo non mi vedo non mi vedono mi
vedo non mi vedono mi vedo non mi vede
non mi vedono mia idea un m m m perfetto
ma anche a tipo la macchina le co non
sono anche se c'è la macchina doveva
dove dovrei andare spiegatemi dove dove
girovagando con lo slider che all
infarti prenderò ed ogni pagina così
catturerà vivas lander me ma che bella
faccia lo guardi e poi si incazza vivas
lander me gender bender land e vogliamo
fare una canzone che lo slam e ultra
accattivante è terrificante pivas lander
me è chiuso sta facendo tipo il moonwalk
porca [ __ ] ma come cazzo sono le
pagine lega ma spiegatemelo che non è
impossibile che le stia trovando da
un'ora e mezza di qua cos'è questo sì
cos'è al metallo me ne faccio un cazzo
vorrei trovare cose qua no vero perfetto
top dove no
eccolo il mega di il dominio mi mancava
la povera statua master quella this land
airmen bellissimo che bei ricordi non
per il lido e pretendono non pensate
male
ok come cazzo creato una torcia a
spiegare dove come aiuto no no no non
devi fermarti porca [ __ ] non ho corso
per due ore come fai essere stanco che
gli obesi negli horror che comandi che
non sanno correre ai don't speak english
non me ne frega un cazzo che non speak
english e voto ho capito dove l'ultima
mista però non ci arriverò mai perché
costo quasi che trasporta come mia nonna
a casa la casa la casa la casa sono
entrato oddio oddio qua dentro ne
troverà non è troppo dentro è la madonna
ho capito è che chi è che sace l'azione
va bene come cazzo dovrei mai riuscire
spiegatemelo credo che l'ultima pagina
ragazzi siano i boiler che non ho
trovato cioè non so dove sono proviamoci
a caso eccoli hanno quindi sono quelli
prima erano quelli grossi grigio che
sembrano vacche due sono i bailey no
devi correre porca [ __ ] che obeso
però madonna come mi sono salvato non lo
so che è lento lento meno panini da
mcdonald e mi addio a troverò mai nella
vita all'ultima pagina lo sapete vero ma
poi dove se non lo vendo neanche da dove
che sa dov'è che fa ste cose cioè
ragazzi sto correndo da mezzo la mabilia
se riesco a trovare questa cazzo di
pagina c'è impossibile no no no eh va
beh va beh non posso più girarmi
[ __ ] devi morire e devi morire tu
ei tuoi pixel
game over ragazzi [ __ ] tutto è stato
carino proprio molto carino il match si
trova il culo con la torcia per cortesia
è una roba che non si può giocare è
impossibile arrivare a piacermi di ti
massacra una roba che se questa figura
qui non voglio saperlo che i ragazzi
conclude episodio è stato carino
comunque mi sembra tori ritornare un po
ai tempi poi minecraft di slam
poi insieme comunque è stato carino da
fare almeno un episodio devo provarci è
andato di merda amen ecco eccolo qua
perfetto vi lascio ragazza in compagnia
di lui che divertiti servito è piaciuto
maastricht ha lasciato momento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come ogni
vino tratta descrizione un mi piace
perché lui sicuramente avrebbe finito il
gioco io nostri siti schifani ci vediamo
proseguito belle ragazze